on the track it's all right just get out
of the car for me okay you're okay I
just need you to get out of the car okay
are you injured just step over here okay
just step over
here belar just send me Ems for uh
precautionary airbag deployment I have
fluids on the roadway as well if you can
start fire just have a seat here hun
come here what's your namey okay just
have a seat I call my mom okay all right
we'll got it taken care of them
okay are you okay
[Music]
yeah we know Transit
pleas
re
bmar 1011 the
tag Bravo 73 Lincoln Lincoln Zulu
contact Bennetts
please what's your name hun Rosie Rosie
how much you had to drink
tonight I met up with my friends and I
had to drink with them
okay so bad okay
what I say
e elar you can correct the location
7even
railroad my
[Music]
arm
my mom's going to be so are you okay to
walk I just want to get you out of
whatever loot out of your car
okay my mom's going to be
so
Wonder uh Transit will take
it it would make
sense just let me know if you're going
to be transporting thank
you 66
we might be able to drive it off here
but I mean it's pretty fucked up can
iems respond to 16th in rail closer to
the South Park and lot of bar for a head
r no I think it's a
neutral no it's not yeah transmission
dropped it says
malfunction
yeah going be correct west of the
track traic stop okay
[Music]
so if we got anything coming froming
southbound conf the
[Music]
St receive thank
you
up
51 I'll be clear nothing matching the
description
[Music]
there
yeah I know train is getting
[Music]
closer where the hell is he
going is there another
call it was a first a
head you can try it I think it's uh it's
keep saying malfunction so I don't know
if it's like a safety feature it won't
shift but yeah you're more than welcome
to give it a
whirl move yeah give it a try
yeah have at
it over
there
okay that's fine you can have step
out R we're going to go right over here
okay just follow me this way watch your
step all right just come this way just
watch your step we're going to go across
the street over here okay just hold on
one second let's make sure the new car
is coming all right we're going to have
a seat over here for the time being all
right just sit and I just want you to
sit and calm down for a few minutes
okay
[Music]
yeah can you just tell yeah never mind
there we go I've seen her something all
right Rosemary can you just stand up for
me we're just going to walk over here
okay just watch your
step just walk over this
way good just stay right here
okay sorry it was busy you said you need
benns yeah affirmative uh if you can
send Bennetts we're going to have one
impound for John's
La all right Rosemary I got to put you
through some some feel sobriety tests
okay do you have any issues with your
eyes or anything like that yeah I wear
glasses you wear glasses and contacts
okay all right what you're going to do
is you're going to turn and you're going
to face me this way okay just turn
you're going to turn and face me this
way okay you're going to stay right
there you know when I do this podcast
I'm conscious about what I wear this is
not by accident when I want to be
presentable to all of you and there is a
place that I want to tell you about
where you can find clothing to buy and a
whole host of other things to buy it's
called deal dash what is that glad you
asked deal dash is an auction website
it's been around for 14 years and they
are now a proud sponsor of sidebar they
have awesome deals super exciting
auctions the way it works is you buy
bids and then you bid on things that
start Z everything on the site starts at
Z and they gave me Jesse Weber from long
crime sidebar $100 which came out to
$770 and let me tell you when I say I'm
bidding hard right now on these psycho
tuna bathing suits I mean Summer's right
around the corner I want them no I need
them okay so what's the catch well you
got to pay upfront to bid so for
instance here after you sign up they ask
you to buy 400 bids for 30 bucks which
means you can bid 400 times in any of
their auctions and by the way they have
some seriously quality items like this
brand new jeep that someone won for
$1,875 a Nintendo switch for
$22 now his deal dash for everyone no
some of the auctions can take hours or
even days on end so you need to invest
time for bidding but if you like bidding
on auctions and you've got the time on
your hands to figure out how it works
you can get some pretty sweet deals so
check out dealdash.com when you you sign
up use my promo code law crime 100 and
you get 100 extra free bids on your
first bid pack purchase and if you don't
win an auction using these bids or you
don't like it for any reason contact
deal dash you get your money back no
questions asked on your first bid pack
purchase so the downside is really
limited it's worth a try now once you're
done finishing this episode of cbar of
course you can check out dealdash.com
law crime 100 all right do you see the
tip of my pen all right I want you to
follow with your eyes don't move your
head okay do you understand that
[Music]
okay all right just keep following with
your eyes
[Music]
okay all the way out here
okay all the way out
I don't know what the point is now my
pents already coming that's okay I just
I need to do these tests okay just keep
folling your eyes don't move your head
okay oh don't fall don't fall you
okay all
right hold on hold on I don't I just
don't want you to
fall all right you sure you're okay all
right you have any injuries to your legs
or back or anything like that I know I'm
bleeding but okay fine I guess do you
want to go to the hospital no I'm going
to go to the hospital for this I'm just
asking you the question I I you're right
I'm just asking okay that's fine okay
the next test I'm going to do is I'm
going to demonstrate it and just you
watch me
okay do you want to do these tests do
you okay I'm asking you I'm giving you
the
option what's the what's the point
because I'm trying to determine your
level of intoxication you have to go
through your protocol that's correct
just to be like okay I went through my
protocol I'm trying to determine your
level of intoxication if you don't wish
to take these tests you don't have to we
you just skip this and go right to
headquarters no I mean we're already
here my airbags are already out of my
car what's Point understand that what's
the point the point is I'm trying to
give you the opportunity to tell to tell
me how intoxicated you are okay without
doing these tests I'm not going to be
able to know all right so would you like
to continue these tests okay okay the
next test I'm going to ask you to do I'm
going to put you in the starting
position okay I want you to imagine a
straight line okay I want I want you to
put your left foot down on that straight
line go ahead and do that I want you to
put your right foot directly in front of
your left foot touching Heel To Toe okay
why don't you go ahead and do
that left foot directly in front of your
right foot touching Heel To Toe like
this Heel To Toe
hun
nope hold on I didn't tell you to start
the test yet I was just trying to put
you in the starting position okay you're
going to put your left foot down on a
straight line and you're going to put
your right foot down directly in front
of your left foot touching Heel To Toe
all right so why don't you go ahead and
do that doesn't matter okay turn around
put CH find your back put your hands
behind your back you're under arrest for
dii seriously yes ma'am you've had a
little too much to drink today do you
have anything in your pockets or
anything like that I have a shooter in
here in here okay yep how is it in the
front pocket yep
okay okay I don't see the shooter in
there but I'll get a female officer to
check you okay we're going to Walk This
Way okay this is so M
County I got
it female 41 450 we're going to go right
this
way oh You' be great yeah
please your step thanks I'm sure you
really care I'm sorry you feel that
way you need someone to run the Box no I
got
it you want to just Pat her down real
quick before I put in the car all right
this female Lo here is just going to
patch down okay do you uh you need me to
come back to the uh yeah yeah please if
you don't
mind pH you want me to take everything
out yeah that'd be
great um there was an open high in the
car I said there was an open high in the
car you could just you could just do a
search in there for intoxic
no we should be good thanks
BR uh it's probably drivable so yeah you
but yeah depending on what the damage is
but they they were able to drive it off
so did she have anything in her front
pocket sorry they're just they're bigs
no I don't think she got anything in
there yeah she should be good you I
can't check
anyway got
it not drivable okay you said it to Ben
yeah
doesn't matter for you I know it doesn't
just put it yeah you can put in
the just put it in the side bin over
here yeah you're going to better take to
the Y out of the no I got the reg
insurance
enjoy I'm sure it was it thank
you if you just get is there there's a
number on there or something just for my
report you can get
that thank you
y right with you guys
want I mean you do did pretty thorough
here but if you want if you don't mind
coming back just check it one more
[Music]
time5 we're coming 103 female
all of the
world all right you're good thank you
Rob
open
Sally yeah she's around the pass can you
just hang with her one second on the
passenger
side all right can you step out for
me no ST this way
okay going to go right through this big
garage door here
okay available unit go to 200th
Boulevard for a lock going to be a
white
right turn left we're going to turn
right just walk straight in and have a
seat
okay up that
lock for thank you need anything else no
should be
good if you could just get me my uh like
case number and time rest is this it uh
no but I'll yeah case number and time
arrest all that stuff
all right I'm going to take your
handcuffs off Rosemary
okay okay yep that
works this officer is just going to do a
little bit more of a thorough pat down
on you okay rub yep uh what
size what's your name again Rosemary
Rosemary I'm glad it's that
intimate all right all right fine it
doesn't we got the toe on the way sorry
about that wrong that's going to the
Y uh trans fem transfit officer is just
going to search her real
quick
I had oh
proba heard
can you get can you just get a her purse
and like her phone out of the
car yeah let me uh you want to just see
bur can do that real
quick you got your
radio inside out you said just what
purse just purse and cell phone okay you
can put back off
you let them have their shoes yeah she
can have them for the time being yep
thank you for time being appreciate that
brother
hey buddy can you do me a
favor
young I
feel oh no I'm
not
just but thank you
anyway it doesn't matter for either of
us
right either way it doesn't
matter fuck me and fuck my car and fuck
my
life it I promise you doesn't
matter it doesn't
nothing nothing
does I just would love to call my mom
but I guess I'm I I guess I'll wait till
I'm allowed too yeah they got to do
their thing and then right they got to
wait till they like beat everybody up
the do you need anything no I appreciate
your help thank you yeah well I'll be
next door for all right cool thank you
all right Rosemary I had to read you the
form okay it's it's long so just bear
with me okay you've been arrested for
driving all intoxicated New Jersey
statute 39450 the law requires you to
submit samples of your breath for the
purpose of testing to determine alcohol
content a record of the taking of the
breath samples including the test
results will be made upon your request a
copy of that record will be made
available to you after you have provided
samples of your breath for testing you
have the right at your own expense to
have a person or pH of your own
selection take independent samples of
your breath blood or urine for
independent testing if you refuse to
provide samples of your breath you will
be issued a separate summons for the
refusal a court may find you guilty of
both refusal and driving while
intoxicated if a court finds you guilty
of the refusal you will be subject to
various penalties including including
license revocation of up to 20 years a
fine of up to
$2,000 installation of an ignition
interlock and referral to an intoxicated
driver resource act these penalties may
be in addition to penalties imposed by
the court for any offense of which you
are found guilty you have no legal right
to have an attorney physician or anyone
else present for the purpose of taking
the breath samples you have no legal
right to refuse to give or delay giving
samples of your of your breath any
response from you that is ambiguous or
conditional in any respect to my request
you provide breath samples will be
treated as a refusal to submit to breath
testing even if you agree to take the
test but then do not follow my
instructions do not properly perform the
test or do not provide sufficient breath
samples I will charge you with refusal
to submit the breath testing I repeat
the law requires you to submit samples
of your breath for testing will you
submit the samples of your
breath okay so you said if I say no
that's the same thing
as doing your breath
test and someone
already your answer is not acceptable
the law requires that you submit samples
of your breath for breath testing if you
do not or answer with anything other
than yes I will charge you with refusal
now I ask you again will you submit
samples of your
breath yeah I rard okay I guess I guess
you're take your shoes off take your
shoes off take your nose rings off
earings everything take my nose rings
off they all have to come
off I can't take my nose rings
off I can do a bread sample but I cannot
take my fucking nose rings off nope
we're past that point
oh what you're fucking the coolest kid
in gym class in high school can earrings
come off no rings no the Rings come off
I cannot take my rings off I can't take
my nose rings off hold on listen to me
listen to me the Rings come off the
earrings come off and the nose rings
come off okay if you can't take
something off I understand but the ring
can come off I know the ring can come
off it's a ring can you please take your
ring off your finger you're going to get
it back but it's it's got to come off
I'm I cannot take this all I don't know
what you want me to do how' you get it
on uh I don't know 10 years ago okay
well I don't know that how how am I
supposed to know that well you're acting
like a fucking dickhead like I I've been
nothing but nice to
you really okay I'm sorry you feel you
don't feel that
way can you please try to take your ring
off I I'm trying
do you think I'm not trying at
all like it I'm I'm
trying there you go there you go I spit
on it I have my saliva brother your
earrings come
out what about your nose do your nose
rings come out or no no they don't come
out not at all okay do you have any
other piercings or any jewelry anywhere
no
okay come right this
way turn left and turn
left nope NOP NOP NOP not this way this
way turn
left this way yep keep walking
straight here
yep turn right do you have somebody we
can call to come get you why can I get
my fucking call bro I'm asking if you
have somebody I would have I done you're
under arrestor driving under under the
influence okay do you have somebody you
can call to come get
you
M4